Je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femme,
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes. Aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement.
Au lendemain de la première guerre mondiale, la France doit être repeuplée;
alors en 1920, les députés, uniquement des hommes, trouvent LA solution :
une loi qui interdit tout bonnement
l'avortement et la contraception !
50 ans et un baby-boom plus tard, malgré la sévérité des peines encourues, on constate que...
La loi de 1920 n’est pas appliquée
Et non
... n'est plus applicable,
Non plus...
Elle est bafouée.
Et voilà !
Et qu’il est toujours mauvais pour un État
de conserver dans sa législation des textes qui sont inappliqués.
Évidemment, tout le monde n’est pas de cet avis
Je suis contre l’avortement parce que l’avortement c’est un échec, le constat d’un échec.
Je pense que la vie est une chose belle, je pense que rien n’est beau comme un enfant
Ça, c’est l’argument des opposants, et pour les défenseurs du progrès, ça ressemble à ça :
Ce que nous proposons s’ordonne autour de deux idées,
la première c’est évidemment la priorité à la contraception, l’avortement c’est toujours un pis-aller.
Et nous considérons que, l’avortement doit être libre parce que le choix de la naissance est un acte conscient.
Pour nous, respecter la vie, ça consiste à choisir le moment où l’on veut donner la vie à un enfant.
A l’époque on estime à 300 000 le nombre de femmes qui se font avorter chaque année
et beaucoup trop en gardent des séquelles voire perdent la vie.
Elle est atteinte de septicémie, c’est à dire d’une infection généralisée, très grave,
et autrefois régulièrement mortelle, à la suite d’un avortement mal fait.
Il faut alors faire comprendre que l’avortement n’est pas une solution de confort ou de facilité
mais un véritable enjeu.
En 1972 a lieu le procès de Bobigny qui est devenu un symbole de ce débat.
Le procès lui même, quel qu’ait été le jugement, le procès lui-même a marqué un pas irréversible
Michèle Chevalier est accusée avec trois autres femmes de s'être rendue complice
de l'avortement de sa fille de 16 ans, enceinte à la suite d'un viol.
Maître Halimi réussit à faire acquitter sa cliente, pour la première fois dans l’histoire.
C’est formidable, les juges ont enfin pris leurs responsabilités,
ils ont pris connaissance des lois, qui n’étaient plus applicables.
C’est alors une certitude; la loi doit changer.
Et c’est Simone Veil, alors ministre de la santé, qui aura la lourde charge de présenter le texte de loi.
Je crois qu’on a oublié aujourd’hui, les jeunes ne savent pas, et tant mieux, ce que c’était.
C’était un problème vraiment très très angoissant pour beaucoup de femmes…
Le débat qui a précédé le vote de la loi a également été ponctué par des attaques violentes,
parfois même absolument sordides.
Ils avaient des pancartes que j’ai eu le temps de lire sur lesquelles il y avait : Veil / Hitler, même combat.
Alors là je ne peux pas ne pas répondre.
Simone Veil ayant survécu aux camps de concentration, le parallèle était carrément nauséabond.
Et je dirai à ceux qui supportaient ces pancartes même s’ils sont sortis, mais je souhaite qu’ils m’entendent,
c’est que ce sont eux qui sont des nazis et que j’en ai la preuve par les courriers qu’ils m’adressent
Le débat est alors extrêmement tendu, la population est divisée et tout le monde à un avis sur la question...
même si tout le monde n’est pas concerné.
Par exemple si une jeune fille de 16, 17 ans est enceinte est-ce qu’elle pourrait se faire avorter selon vous ?
Non, non, parce qu’après ça va être… on s’en sort plus quoi…
Vous pensez qu’il y aurait des abus ?
Ce serait la porte ouverte quoi
La porte ouverte à quoi ?
Bah, à tous les abus, à tous… On se dira on peut y aller tranquillement
puisque on aura toujours la porte de secours
Ce qui a été tout de même très désagréable dans le débat..
C’est la façon dont il a été faussé par des mouvements d’opinion à l'extérieur.
Il faut alors faire comprendre que l’avortement est un véritable problème
qui se doit d’être dépénalisé pour pouvoir être contrôlé.
Faire comprendre également les raisons qui poussent certaines femmes à interrompre leurs grossesse.
Mon mari n’a pas encore terminé son service militaire et je travaille,
je ne peux pas élever un deuxième enfant pour l’instant
Je suis jeune mariée, j’ai eu un bébé un petit peu trop tôt à mon avis
et que j’aimerais en avoir un dans plusieurs années, pas tout de suite.
Tout de suite après, il y eut pour moi l’avortement, parce que une femme violée le premier besoin qu’elle a
c’est de se laver, de laver son corps, d’enlever toutes les traces, toutes les marques encore qui restent sur elle.
Et puis moi quand j’ai appris que j’étais enceinte c’était affreux
Le 5 avril 1971, 343 femmes lancent l'appel "des 343" et clament :
"Un million de femmes se font avorter chaque année, je déclare que je suis l'une d'elles"
Je me demande si cette loi aurait eu lieu si on avait pas commencé par signer le manifeste des 343,
on nous a appelé quelquefois les 343 salopes,
un manifeste où nous disions que dans notre vie nous nous étions toutes faites avortées.
Pendant que texte de loi se prépare, le débat devient national.
Nous, élus locaux, nous n’acceptons pas ce qui se prépare
Visiblement ils sont contre
Mais nous ne pensons pas que la solution soit le permis légal de tuer
Les arguments des anti-IVG ramènent souvent le débat autour de la question de la vie à venir,
sans prendre en compte celle de la mère et des difficultés qu’elle peut rencontrer.
Ah moi, l’avortement je suis pour !
Ah !
C’est absolument incroyable, on voit que ce sont les hommes qui font les lois
parce que s’il leur arrivait quelques fois d’avoir les problèmes des femmes, ils comprendraient
plus facilement qu’il faut absolument que ce problème se règle très très rapidement.
Alors c’est avec autant de finesse que d’intelligence que Simone Veil va présenter son projet, à l’assemblée.
Je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire partager une conviction de femme,
je m’excuse de le faire devant cette assemblée presque exclusivement composée d’hommes.
Aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de coeur à l’avortement.
Aucune. Jamais.
Je le dis avec toute ma conviction, l’avortement doit rester l’exception,
l’ultime recours pour des situations sans issue.
Ça c’est pour ceux qui pensent que certaines avortent pour le fun !
C’est toujours un drame, cela restera toujours un drame.
Et bien sûr, derrière cette loi il y a des femmes, leur intégrité physique et psychologique, et parfois leur vies.
Actuellement, celles qui se trouvent dans cette situation de détresse, qui s’en préoccupe ?
Puis elle va interroger les opposants à la loi sur leur “jugement” face à une réalité bien plus amère.
Parmi ceux qui combattent aujourd’hui une éventuelle modification de la loi répressive,
combien sont-ils ceux qui se sont préoccupés d’aider ces femmes dans leur détresse ?
Combien sont-ils ceux qui au-delà de ce qu’ils jugent comme une faute
ont su manifester aux jeunes mères célibataires la compréhension
et l’appui moral dont elles avaient un si grand besoin ?
La loi Veil du 15 janvier 1975 autorise l’interruption volontaire de grossesse.
Un texte provisoire est voté pour 5 ans. Le vote définitif aura lieu en 1979.
Les gens ont senti que, au delà du sujet, il y avait une femme qui était seule
au milieu de ces hommes qui étaient d’une agressivité, d’une oppression, d’une…
je dirai… d’une vulgarité vis-à-vis de la femme. Ils avaient l’impression que c’était… Qu’on leur arrachait le pouvoir,
le pouvoir politique, mais aussi on les atteignait dans leurs, heu, dans leur virilité, dans leur sexualité…
Aujourd’hui, en France il existe toujours des mouvements qui veulent limiter, voire interdire l'IVG.
Et l'accès réel des femmes y est très inégal selon les territoires
et encore sous-tendu de bien trop de jugements.
Au planning familial du département, personne ne décroche et sur place on trouve porte close.
Certaines femmes se trouvent donc livrées à elles-mêmes et manquent d’informations.
À l’international, la situation diffère selon les pays :
par exemple l’Irlande progresse sur la question, tandis que l’Argentine y est toujours opposée
et que l’Espagne l’a récemment remise en cause.
Nous devons soutenir les femmes pour que l’avortement leur reste accessible.
La société, quel que soit son développement économique ou le régime politique qui la gouverne,
a encore du mal à concéder aux femmes la liberté de décider si elles veulent ou non poursuivre une grossesse.
"L'avortement, c’est nous, c’est nous, c’est nous qui décidons !"
Et pour citer Simone de Beauvoir : "N'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira d'une crise politique, économique ou religieuse
pour que les droits des femmes soient remis en question. Ces droits ne sont jamais acquis.
Vous devrez rester vigilantes votre vie durant."